hey there guys so I just uploaded a
video about body language very recently
if you haven't seen that already then I
highly recommend you go and check it out
I'll give a bit more context what I'm
going to talk about here basically
though I wanted to share one more
example of how you can read body
language cues and use that to your
advantage in this case I want to talk
about how you can use it to spot a lie
or truth this is incredibly difficult
and in fact it's thought by many that
this can't be done with much reliable
accuracy but there are are tells often
simply looking for anxiety and stress
can suggest that solvent isn't being
entirely truthful this is how polygraph
works by assessing someone's base level
of stress we can then look for signs
that they're becoming uncomfortable such
as fidgeting increased heart rate
pacifying behaviors like nail biting we
can then assume that perhaps they're
uncomfortable because they're lying
the well-documented problem with this
approach there is that people tend to be
nervous when being interrogated
so either you avoid making it seem like
an interrogation in the first place or
you look for other potential signs of
lying one cognitive sign would be
noticeable pauses inventing lies is more
cognitive demanding than telling the
truth and so the person might use more
filler words and take longer when
explaining themselves likewise you might
see signs having congruence with their
body language for instance the song
tells you that they went left whilst
gesturing right this is certainly a
cause for suspicion this happens once
again due to embodied cognition the
person is picturing themselves running
right as they recall what happened
watch how someone just stick you a
player described their home to you and
you might find you can ascertain all
sorts of interesting things non-verbally
such as the height of their cabinets or
where their bedroom is in relation to
the front door while some might remember
to lie with what they're saying is much
harder to remember to control your
gestures more often a liar will simply
just stick you ate less and there is
less emotional engagement with what
they're saying
so to summarize basically if you're
trying to look for a live and there are
a few things that you can keep an eye
out for firstly if they pause for a long
time in between what they're saying then
that means they might be fabricating it
at the same time you should look for
signs of nervousness
to make sure that you're avoiding other
reasons for them to be nervous so if
you're an interview setting for instance
try and make them as calm as possible
ask some normal questions establish a
baseline that way I'll then be more
obvious if someone is nervous or if
they're taking time in answering their
questions another tip is to look out for
in congruence between their body
language and what they're saying and in
particular look out for a lack of body
language if someone has a lack of
gesticulation if they're not really
emphasizing the things that they're
saying I want to say it has been a
pleasure to work alongside all of you
for the past twenty one and a half
months I'm sorry for getting so
emotional and that might once more
indicate that they could be lying to
improve your chances keep the
conversation going as long as possible
to get them to elaborate on the things
they say and keep on talking I wouldn't
to review that I'd like you to review
that right now can you tell me who wrote
that phrase until eventually they'll
hopefully trip themselves up and make a
mistake it's highly likely that I wrote
that what percentage likely yeah
probably 90% likely that I wrote that
you wrote that didn't you okay yeah
today again that's how you can use these
body language skills in order to
hopefully more accurately detect a lie
thanks Stan for watching guys hope
thanks pretty useful interesting if you
did then please leave a like and share
around that helps me out immensely
comment down below and let me know of
any tips you know for spotting a lie or
any instances in your life where you've
been able to spot someone lying I've got
lots more videos like this on the way
I've just filmed a couple more on
different types of training in
particular work capacity and one where
you can train your biceps every single
day so if that sounds cool then thanks
time for watching again and I'll see you
next time
bye for now